the Joe Rogan experience do you do you
get frustrated by the the time
constraints of the debates absolutely
it's you shouldn't even call them a
debate what they are is a you know
reality TV show in which you have to
come up with a soundbite know that stuff
it is the meaning it's the meaning to
the candidates and it's the meaning to
the American people you can't explain
the complexity of health care in America
in 45 seconds nobody can but why is it
still done that way if you try to do
what's Pulis thing you know I think the
DNC is in a difficult position
they have 20-plus candidates and they
want to give everybody a fair shot which
is the right thing to do and then if
you're gonna have 10 candidates up on
the stage what do you do but there are
other ways that we've got to do it
because the issues facing this country
are so enormous and in some cases so
complicated nobody in the world can
honestly explain them in 45 seconds and
that what encourages people to do is to
come up with sound bites and do absurd
things so if I yelled and screamin the
show I took my clothes off we get a lot
of publicity right yeah they give a
thoughtful answer to a complicated
question it's not so sexy for the media
you don't even have a chance to give a
thoughtful answer like Tulsi Gabbard
went after Kamala Harris and then Kamala
Harris at about 12 seconds to reply to
it it was so ridiculous to do to have
something that's such an important issue
did you or did you not put all those
people in jail for marijuana did you
laugh about it did this happen did that
happen all these different things with
was evidence withheld that's how these
are a long conversations but it takes us
to another issue and that is a nation we
do a pretty bad job in analyzing and
discussing the serious issues facing our
country and I hold the media to some
degree responsible for that you know
other countries what they do is that you
Joe you want to run for president okay
but whether your party in the general
election we're going to give you a
certain amount of time hours on
television and you use those hours
anyway you want one hour 15 minute
discuss you remember Ross Perot yes and
people used to laugh at Ross Perot
because he used to get up there with a
chart and all this stuff and and the
media made fun of him but in fact he
tried in his own way to explain his
point of view to the American people and
we need serious discussion on serious
issues well he had the army because he
was so rich he had the ability to buy
airtime on network television which is
pretty unprecedented he just bought a
chunk of airtime and then fled his case
but you know what goes on in other
countries you don't have to buy that
time what the obligation is if you are a
network you're gonna make that time free
and available to candidates do you think
that that's something that could be
viable in America could could you
convince CBS and NBC and ABC to go along
with something like that no you couldn't
convince them you'd have to pass
legislation to make that happen but
everyone's online today that mean the
entire country is essentially getting
email and Facebook and all that jazz
like why bother doing it in this
particular medium that has an inherent
time constraint well you're right I mean
the Internet has revolutionized politics
and in many ways good ways we use our
social media our email list which is
very large we every day we're sending
out stuff and other candidates are doing
it the same way but television still has
a very important role to be playing I'm
sure it does but I mean the ability to
discuss things in in long-form what you
can do online like you can do right here
right now like you can't get that on
television what you could I mean if you
had what the state had to interrupt you
every 15 minutes no no no no no what I'm
saying about is it's in what goes on in
other countries if I'm not mistaken I
don't hold me this I think in the UK you
remember the Labour Party you're a
candidate mm-hm here's 30 minutes of
time and you do with it as you want you
want to speak 30 minutes on health care
whatever it may be you can do that
really yeah and they don't interrupt
with commercial no no no no that's the
law that they have given this is the
candidates opportunity to speak at
length to the people of the country